DO IT VERY, VERY CAREFULLY.
TUCKER?
>> Tucker: GREAT METAPHOR.
THANKS, ED.
IS THE NEW DEAL WITH NORTH KOREA
ACTUALLY A DEAL THAT IS GOOD FOR
THE UNITED STATES?
CAN WE TRUST THE UNITED STATES
TO FOLLOW IT?
DOUG McGREGOR IS HERE, THE
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE STATE OF
NEBRASKA ALSO JOINS US TONIGHT.
CONGRESSMAN, FIRST TO YOU.
IS THIS A DEAL THAT AMERICANS
OUGHT TO BE HAPPY ABOUT?
>> THE BEST WORD THAT I COULD
USE TO DESCRIBE THE LAST FEW
DAYS IS STUNNING.
IT'S ALMOST UNIMAGINABLE GIVEN
WHERE WE WERE JUST SIX MONTHS
AGO WHERE WE WERE ON THE
PRECIPICE OF SOME TYPE OF EVEN
POTENTIAL NUCLEAR EXCHANGE.
THE PRESIDENT HAS LEANED INTO
SOMETHING PRETTY RADICAL HERE
AND PERHAPS IT'S A NEW
ARCHITECTURE FOR 20 PER CENTURY
DIPLOMACY.
HE HAS SAID TO KIM JONG UN, WE
WILL DEAL WITH YOU FOR GOOD OR
FOR ILL.
IF IT'S FOR ILL, WE WILL HURT
YOU.
IF IT'S GOOD, IT WILL CREATE THE
SPACE FOR PERHAPS AUTHENTIC
DIALOGUE AND FRIENDSHIP AND I
THINK HE ACCOMPLISHED THAT.
HE HAS REJECTED THE NORMS OF
OSSIFIED PROCEDURAL IS HIM AND
STAGNATION THAT GOVERN SO MANY
INTERNATIONAL AFFAIRS AND HE
TOOK A BOLD RISK AND DELIVERED
SOMETHING VERY IMPORTANT.
IT'S AN IMPORTANT AND GOOD FIRST
STEP.
>> Tucker: OSSIFIED PROCEDURAL
REALISM.
THAT'S A PHRASE I'M STEALING.
COLONEL, ARE YOU AS OPTIMISTIC?
>> EXTREMELY, I THINK THIS IS
DONALD TRUMP'S FINEST HOUR, AND
I'M SERIOUS.
DONALD TRUMP HAS RECOGNIZED
SOMETHING THAT OTHERS HAVE
REFUSED TO SEAT FOR A VERY LONG
TIME IN WASHINGTON.
IT'S NOT SIMPLY THAT NORTH KOREA
IS ON THE ROPES, IT IS.
IT'S ON THE VERGE OF COLLAPSE.
DONALD TRUMP UNDERSTOOD THAT AND
HE ALSO WENT TO GREAT LENGTHS IN
HIS MEETINGS WITH THE PRESIDENT
SHE
XI, TREATED THEM AS EQUALS.
I THINK DONALD TRUMP UNDERSTAND
SOMETHING THAT WAS NOT WELL
UNDERSTOOD IN THE PENTAGON AT
THIS POINT OR IN MANY OTHER
PLACES IN WASHINGTON AND THAT
OUR COMPETITION WITH CHINA IS
ESSENTIALLY TECHNOLOGIC AND NOT
MILITARY.
THAT WAS THE KEY DEVELOPMENT
BECAUSE WITHOUT CHINA NONE OF
THIS WOULD HAVE HAPPENED.
>> Tucker: AND HEAT IT CLEARLY
STAND WITH WHAT HE SAID ABOUT
TRADE FROM CHINA.
CONGRESSMAN, THERE'S BEEN A LOT
OF TRADE STOMACH CRITICISM OF
THIS DEAL FROM THE LEFT, WITH
THE IDEA THAT THE PRESIDENT HAS
BEEN GIVING AWAY THINGS IN
EXCHANGE FOR NOTHING.
SPEAK OUT THIS IS THE
COMBINATION OF FOREIGN POLICY
REALISM AND ENTREPRENEURIAL
DIPLOMACY.
AS I SAID, THIS IS NOT JUST
POTENTIALLY PREVENTING A
CONFLICT AND REJECTING A
STALEMATE OF THE LAST 65 YEARS
WITH NORTH KOREA, BUT IT ALSO
COULD SIGNAL A NEW
COULD SIGNAL A NEW WAY, A NEW
ARCHITECTURE FOR DIPLOMATIC
RELATIONS MOVING FORWARD.
THE WORLD IS SCREAMING FOR SOME
TYPE OF NEW INTERPERSONAL ECHO
SYSTEM BOTH IN OUR HOMES AND
COMMUNITIES, AS WELL AS BETWEEN
NATIONS.
WHAT THAT MEANS IS YOU HAVE TO
HAVE THE ABILITY TO REACH OUT
AND PROVIDE AUTHENTICITY AND
DIALOGUE AND CREATE SOME SPACE.
THE WORLD
DESTRUCTIVE TECHNOLOGY, AND THEN
WHAT?
CIVILIZATION ITSELF IS AT STAKE
AND WE HAVE TO FIND A WAY
TOWARDS MUTUALITY, WELL-BEING
AND MUTUAL SECURITY.
OTHERWISE WE DON'T HAVE MUCH
HOPE.
>> Tucker: COLONEL, LIBERALS
AND SOME CONSERVATIVES BY THE
WAY CRITICIZED THAT YOU MEET
WITH SOMEONE WHO IS MORALLY
OUT-OF-BOUNDS, LIKE KIM JONG UN.
GOING FORWARD, SHOULD WE BE
WILLING TO MEET WITH ANYBODY?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
DONALD TRUMP IS A DISRUPTIVE
FORCE, LET'S BE FRANK.
IT'S DISRUPTING THE STATUS QUO.
LOTS OF PEOPLE IN THIS TOWN ARE
UPSET BECAUSE IT THREATENS TO
CHANGE THE DISTRIBUTION OF CASH.
IT THREATENS THE CASH, IT
THREATENS ITS SUPPORT
STRUCTURES.
OTHER THINGS HE RECOGNIZED EARLY
ON WHEN HE WAS CAMPAIGNING.
SOUTH KOREA IS A POWERFUL STATE,
INFINITELY MORE POWERFUL THAN
NORTH KOREA AND HE RECOGNIZED
THAT JAPAN IS IN THE SAME
POSITION.
IF JAPAN RAISES ITS INVESTMENT
IN THE MILITARY POWER BY JUST
1%, JAPAN WILL BE NUMBER THREE
IN THE WORLD IN TERMS OF DEFENSE
BUDGET.
HE UNDERSTANDS THAT WHAT
NORTHEAST ASIA WANTS AND NEEDS
IS STABILITY, ORDER AND
PROSPERITY, NOT WAR.
HE HAS THE AGREEMENT OF EVERYONE
WHO COUNTS IN THE REGION.